The time has come!
For me to lend my infinite, perfect wisdom
on this planet.
Either.io, the game of would you rather?
That's right. We're doing another episode of this
on my own free will
not because I saw someo- some other youtuber
recently make a video about it
And I'm like
"Yeah those used to get pretty good views.
Maybe I'll make another one of those"
But you should be thanking me
Okay?
My morals are absolutely perfect
Okay, let's begin this stupid game. Okay
Would you rather become a superhero or become a supervillain. To be fair,
there's no cool supervillain. There's very few of them. They always make them so lame
I think that's the problem with superhero movies these days. Is just the villains are so lackluster. Back in the day, you know Joker, Bane
Badasses, you know, what are they now?
Sergeant birdman
sergeant
squad Fam Bird
Turtle man
cat killer
Nah, I'll become a superhero, easy. Moving on
oh
and please do
Leave your comments and thoughts in the comments in the comment section.
Would you rather be able to fly or be able to breathe underwater?
What do you think I'm some sort of fucking fish? Do I look like a fish to you? If I can fly,
then that means no effort, okay?
At least that's how I look at flying. If i- flying means I have to do this all the fucking time, then nah, fam
I don't want to fly. Okay, I'll take the breathing underwater
I'll take the option where I don't have to put any effort, but if flying just means "Hey, I would like to go there" *Bzzz*
I'll take it. Thank you. Easy!
Can you get me some tiff- difficult questions please? This is too easy.
Would you rather never be able to make a compliment?
*thinks*
This is the easiest one I ever heard
Why would I want to make a compliment? I'm trying to wrap my head around- never be able to compliment
*thinks again*
That.. supposed to be a bad thing? I don't.. Or never be able to complain. Well I think the choice is pretty obvious
*laugh*
What?!
*surprised*
What are you, pussy boys?! 77% don't want to complain?! What are you, fucking b-b-g
Gay? You never want to complain? Okay well then you can't complain about this: you're a little bitch. How about that
Are you going to complain about it? You can't
Jesus Christ
Would you rather never have sex again or never learn anything new?
Well again, the choice is obvious. Masturbation
Does that count as sex? I change my mind. I change my miiiiind!
Fuck you. Would you rather be visited by Ancient Aliens or
by mole p- what the fuck is mole people?
Is that even a question? That's-
*laughs*
Great, great. That's like asking someone
"Hey,
would you rather meet the president or this homeless man?
I will be visited by the mole people.
The people living in our dirt and ground instead of the ancient aliens that can borrow u- that can borrow to us
Ancient technology, which y- could save humanity. No, thank you. I would like the mole people. I'll pick the mole people."
Would you rather be part of a real giraffe?
Would you rather be part of a real Jurassic park scenario or be part of a real day-after-tomorrow scenario?
Jurassic Park. It's like, "Would you like to be cold for a couple hours or would you like to be eaten by a badass dinosaur?"
I'll- I'll take the dinosaur. Would you rather glue your eyes shut with Superglue or
spill hot glue over your naked lap? Easy
Spill a hot glue over my naked lap. I've done it a couple times. It's a very sexually pleasuring experience
I did it once by accident, and then I'm like, "Huh, that was pretty good." Would you rather live in a homeless shelter
with internet acces
Okay. Or live an amazing house isolated from any outside contact? Well, you didn't say that I can't have internet
Okay, you just said no outside contact. How amazing is this house?
You know? Does it have a bowling alley? Does it have a private helicopter?
I- I- It's too vague. I'm gonna have to go with a homeless shelter. Well
I guess you're all a bunch of fucking idiots, huh? 2% of you are a bunch of idiots
Congratulations. You want to live without Pewdiepie videos? Is that what you're trying to tell me? Moving on.. would you rather kill someone? Yes
Oh wait, maybe I should read the full thing. And have nobody know? Yes
or
Not kill someone but have everyone think you did. I'll just fucking kill someone. What are you, stupid?
I thought about this the other day, okay? People say, "I will never kill anyone" But I'm like
"Mm-mm." No, I think everyone will kill someone. I think it's in our blood, okay? I think if
If given the right circumstance, you would kill someone, okay? If there was a button in front of you, and it said, "Well,
If you don't kill this guy, all the people in the world is going to die", okay?
You would kill it. Anyone would kill with the right circumstance, okay?
So don't fucking bullshit me with that shit. "I wouldn't kill anyone." Yeah you would
Okay, you would. You would
I'd kill you for having shitty opinions.
Moving on,
would you rather fight the entire Smurf Village
Or fight the full collection of Care Bears?
What's a care bear?
Oh my God, yes
I would- I would not just fight them
I would beat the shit out of them, and then when they're laying on the ground
I would take down my pants. I would unzip my huge-
Would you rather win an Oscar or win the Nobel Prize?
Here's what the question is actually saying: would you rather
People look up to you and praise you and love you
*burp*
or
Would you actually like to help s- help society? Would you actually like to do something good for humankind? But most people probably
wouldn't give a shit. *laugh*
Would you rather have to wear a full-body red leotard on your wedding day-
but, that's what I was planning to wear
Thank you very much.
So what's a red leotard?
Hell yeah. Can you imagine me in that? That looks sexy
or have to have the person you are marrying
that day wear the full body red leotard?
So, Marzia in a sexy red leotard or me in a sexy red leotard?
Uh, excuse me. Marzia, I will have the privilege of looking hot in our wedding day, okay?
Would you rather be best friends with Harry Potter or be best friends with Katniss Everdeen?
Who the fuck is Katniss Everdeen?
Oh my God, I don't want to be friends with any one of these fa-
I hated Jennifer Lawrence before it was cool
Okay? Way before it was cool
I saw through her obnoxiousness miles away. Her giant ego, her, (werid accent) "Oh look. I am le humble.
I am a little drunk right now, guys. I might say something totally crazy!
*laugh in a weird way*
I am Jennifer Lawrence
Please, everybody, love me. Look how bootiful I am. Look how humble I am."
Would you rather take a sizzling hot shower or an ice cold freezing shower?
Well, I don't want permanent
bu- damage to my body
So I'll take the ice cold one, because I'm a Swedish viking man and not a little pussy boy.
"Ooh! It's a little cold"
Ooh! My balls went inside my body."
That's normal, okay?
It's called masculinity.
Gets 2% of fucking bitches.
How about that?
Congratulations.
Would you rather slam your hand in every door or
fall down every flight of stairs?
I would rather die. How about that? Which one will most likely kill me? The stairs
I'll pick that one. Thank you.
Well I guess- I guess
515,000 people are fucking idiots
Goddamn it pisses me off. So you're not paying attention to my morals? You're picking the wrong-
You need help, you need guidance in your life
Stop making bad choices. Bad choices kill people.
Would you rather have a stylist do your hair and makeup every day or
Have a fashionista  pick a new outfit every day.
I don't like when people dress me
It was really fucking weird doing Scare Pewdiepie. We had a- she was very nice
But her job was to dress me, and I wasn't allowed to wear my own clothes
And it just really pissed me off because I'm like, "Oh, you don't want any form of authenticity
in this show? You just want me to look like a goddamn product that you guys built?"
I don't know why it bothers me so much, but
Hair- hair and makeup. Do my hair and makeup. I don't give a shit. Okay, well I guess
60% people are fucking wrong, okay?
Would you rather always wear Crocs or always wear socks with sandals?
Can I pick both? I love Crocs, okay?
Have you worn Crocs? Everyone hating on Crocs like it's a meme, like you can't think for yourself. "Oh Crocs are so ugly
because that one meme
I saw online said it."
They're fucking comfortable as shit, and they say the exact same thing with sandals and socks, okay?
"Oh, I know about them. You can't wear sandals and socks. (weird noises)"
I wear sandals and socks. It's comfortable as fuck. You can't stop me, okay?
"Oh, you can't do it because someone else said that you can't do it (whiny noise)"
God damn, it pissed me off
Fuck you. You can't think for that shit
You're not worthy of my fashion. You're not worthy of my morals. Fuck you. Leave a like on this video by the way. Appreciate it.
Thank you so much. Leave a like if you like Crocs and leave a like if you like sandals. This has been, your boy, PewDiePie